hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren Folge Höhle der Löwen Part 3
mittlerweile es geht wieder um
innovative Produkte und den Test ob
diese Produkte wirklich innovativ sind
und ob sie ihr funding verdient haben
oder ob es schlau gewesen wäre mehr Geld
reinzustecken wie auch immer wir starten
mit dem ersten Produkt
Sunny Cage 200.000 € für 10 % dadurch
einen Firmenwert von 2 Millionen Euro
hatten sie angefragt bekommen haben sie
keinen dealen dieses Produkt kostet im
Verkauf 35 € und ist im Prinzip ein
rotierender Toaster Aufsatz der ist uns
ermöglichen soll alte Brötchen auf dem
Toaster wieder frisch zu machen denn ihr
kennt das ist Sonntag ihr habt vergessen
einzukaufen ihr wollt nicht raus was
auch immer ihr habt noch alte Brötchen
da und dieses Ding soll die Lösung dafür
sein ohne an Strom angeschlossen zu
werden einfach so passend auf jeden
Toaster und das schauen uns jetzt mal
gemeinsam an und nein ich habe alte
Brötchen und ich kann sie so nicht essen
es wäre viel zu schwer Sie einfach kurz
mit etwas Wasser in den Backofen zu tun
glücklicherweise gibt es Sunny Cage die
deutlich aufwendigere Option das ganze
auf dem Toaster zu machen also ihr habt
gehört worum es geht die Brötchen sollen
da drin wieder frisch werden dafür haben
wir Brötchen von heute morgen die sind
nicht richtig alt aber liegen jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon 12 Stunden rum
Crunch haben die nicht mehr an die sind
einfach komplett weich glücklicherweise
habe ich den Sunny Cage der wird hier
oben einfach drauf gestellt dann machen
wir das ganze auf das kommt das Brötchen
hier in den käf
das passt nicht es passt wieder nicht es
ist ein handelsübliches Brötchen er
passt nicht richtig rein wir schmeißen
das rein wir spannen ihn wir starten den
Toaster und lassen das Ganze laufen
welche Stufe ist empfohlen
keine Ahnung ich habe die Verpackung
weggeworfen jetzt ist die Frage können
wir den Sunny Cage öffnen ohne dass wir
uns die Finger verbrennen
hört mal genau hin
was wirklich gut
hoffentlich geil weniger trocken als
gedacht ziemlich cool ein Riesending was
man dann natürlich auch irgendwie in der
Küche rum stehen hat nur um alte
Brötchen zu machen es ist so ein Produkt
das mehr win als loose ich würde es mir
wahrscheinlich nicht kaufen aber wenn
man hat oder geschenkt bekommt ist nice
für Produkt Nummer 2 brauchen wir nichts
außer unser Handy es geht nämlich um den
größten Einzelbild der Geschichte von
Höhle der Löwen Finanzen angefragt
hatten sie eine Millionen Euro für 10 %
bekommen haben sie eine Millionen Euro
für 15 % von Carsten Maschmeyer was
einen Firmenwert von 6,6 Millionen Euro
ergibt und tatsächlich kenne und nutze
ich die App schon etwas länger und mir
war gar nicht bewusst dass sie bei Höhle
der Löwen Fanning bekommen hat was das
alles noch ein bisschen cooler macht und
in dem Moment wo ich gemerkt habe dass
über Höhle der Löwen waren dachte ich
dass sie eigentlich der perfekte Partner
für dieses Video waren habe sie
angerufen und tatsächlich unterstützen
Sie freundlicherweise dieses Video die
App ist ein digitaler finanzassistent
der alle eure Einnahmen Ausgaben über
verschiedene Konten verteilt Track das
ganze ist komplett kostenlos ihr könnt
alle eure Konten eintragen sogar
scalable capital und habe dadurch euer
Depot auch noch mit in der
Finanzübersicht ihr seht was reinkommt
ihr seht was aufgeht und vor allem wohin
was rausgeht ihr seht alle eure Verträge
ihr könnt diese Verträge in der App
direkt rechtssicher kündigen und ihr
seht euer Sparpotenzial also wie viel
bleibt am Ende des Monats
durchschnittlich bei euch übrig und mit
wie viel könnt ihr dadurch am Ende des
Monats zum Sparen rechnen vielleicht
zeigt euer Konto 2000 € an aber es
müssen noch 500 € Miete und 50 €
Handyvertrag weg dann weiß finanzguru
dass ihr nur noch 450 € frei zur
Verfügung habt das ganze ist unheimlich
wichtig wenn ihr investieren wollt dass
ihr einfach wisst mit wie viel Geld am
Ende des Monats kann ich rechnen oder
ihr legt es weg von Urlaub oder was auch
immer euer Ziel über den ersten Link in
der Videobeschreibung und mit dem Code
Dave könnt ihr finanzguru Plus für ganze
drei Monate kostenlos testen und das Abo
endet nach drei Monaten ihr verfallt
also nicht automatisch in irgendein Abo
Falle sondern ihr könnt das wirklich
einfach guten Gewissens einfach
ausprobieren mit finanzguru plus hast du
zusätzlich zur Grundversion noch weitere
Features wie tiefere Analysen smarte
budgetvorschläge oder das frei
verfügbare Einkommen zur Verfügung das
ganze ist ansonsten komplett kostenlos
mega sicher und auch große Partner wie
die Deutsche Bank kooperieren mit
finanzguru und jetzt ladet euch die App
herunter registriert euch verknüpft eure
kommenden tragt den Code Dave über den
Reiter mehr ein und erlangt so vollen
Überblick über eure Finanzen und jetzt
viel Spaß mit dem weiteren Produkten
Produkt Nummer 3 sehr oft von euch
angefragt es geht um Boxershorts silver
Tim Tech eine Firma die 120.000 für 15 %
angefragt hat damit Ihre Firma selber
mit 800 000 € bewertet hat sie haben
kein Deal bekommen und wir schauen uns
jetzt an ob das gerechtfertigt war oder
ob wir Ihnen Kohle um Kohle und Kohle in
den Rachen hätten werfen sollen so kam
das ganze hier an äh insgesamt muss ich
sagen dass der Pitch sehr unangenehm war
es wurde sich ausgezogen und so weiter
dafür konnten wir Nico Rosberg auch in
Boxershort begutachten drei Boxershorts
werden für 79 € verkauft das bedeutet
pro Stück bezahlt man 26 €. so sehen sie
aus es sind Boxershorts wunder mich
gerade auf der Website wurde nämlich
eigentlich von einer tollen Verpackung
magnetverpackung gesprochen die
ja das kein Witz das haben die wirklich
auf ihrer Website geschrieben damit die
Boxershorts nicht lieblos im Schrank
rumliegen sondern die immer einen
vernünftigen Ort haben die habe ich
leider nicht dazu bekommen das sieht
jetzt aus wie ein völlig normaler Karton
den werde ich natürlich nicht bei mir in
den Schrank stellen aber es kam ein
Zettel dazu sorry ihr habt uns mit der
Bestellung überwältigt deshalb hat es
dieses Mal etwas länger gedauert als
kleine wieder gut machen bekommst du
einmalig 15 € Rabatt auf deinen nächsten
Einkauf den Code nenne ich euch
natürlich nicht denn ich glaube dass
dieses Produkt rein gar nichts bringt
warum das schauen wir uns gleich
gemeinsam an diese Boxershorts sollen
vor elektromagnetischer Strahlung
schützen die laut den Gründern selber
dazu führen soll dass Männer weniger
fruchtbar sind dass man weniger Power
beim Sport hat weil weniger toll
Testosteron ausgeschüttet wird und so
weiter erstmal Verarbeitung hier oben
das sieht schon mal nicht so mega geil
genäht aus hier drin ist so ein
engmaschiger silberstoff verbaut der vor
den Strahlen schützen soll natürlich
habe ich extra einen
elektromagnetfeldmesser bestellt und
damit werden wir die Strahlung jetzt
testen also wir haben hier mein Handy
erstmal ohne silver Tim das hier ist der
elektromagnetfeldmesser wir legen ihn
drauf ich habe keine Ahnung ob das
irgendein Unterschied macht
16 mg und es piept das bedeutet es ist
schlecht jetzt wollen wir hoffen dass
silver ten etwas dagegen tut wird wieder
weniger wenn es nicht auf dem Handy ist
der extra Stoff von silbertin befindet
sich hier das sehen wir auch hier
mittendrin und legen das drauf legen das
drauf
[Musik]
und es bringt gar nichts es wirkt sogar
als würde es schlechter werden
starten den Speedtest wir legen
Boxershorts hin
17,4 17,3 18
17 21 22 also wir konnten sehen dass
etwas weniger elektromagnetische
Strahlung durch diese knapp 27 Euro
Boxershorts durchgekommen ist warum
finde ich aber trotzdem dass das absolut
völliger Quatsch ist erstmal vorweg ich
bin kein Physiker ich habe überhaupt
keine Ahnung das Bundesamt für
Strahlenschutz was aber direkt vom Bund
kommt hat Leute die schlau genug sind um
das alles zu bewerten und da gibt's ein
extra Dread dazu beeinflusst die
Handynutzung die männliche Fruchtbarkeit
was ja der Haupt claim von Silver tim
ist zur Frage ob hochfrequente
elektromagnetische Felder wie sie zum
Beispiel beim Telefonieren mit dem Handy
auftreten einen Einfluss auf die
männliche Fruchtbarkeit haben wurden
zahlreiche nationale und internationale
Studien durchgeführt die Gesamtbewertung
der Studien zeigt dass bei Einhaltung
der für Mobiltelefone gültigen
Begrenzung und technische Normen kein
schädlicher Einfluss hochfrequenter
elektromagnetischer Felder auf Hoden und
Samenzellen nachgewiesen wurde weder bei
Menschen noch bei Tieren noch bei
Samenzellen das ist die Bewertung der
Bundeszentrale und da hilft es auch
nicht dass auf der Server zum Website
geschrieben wird dass es mit
Wissenschaftlern entwickelt wurde also
ich halte das für völligen quatsch ich
habe das Gefühl es wird so ein bisschen
mit der Angst gespielt mit der Angst der
Kunden gespielt es wird ein Problem
gelöst dass kein Problem ist die
Abstimmung vor hochfrequenter Strahlung
die sich in dem völligen Normalbereich
bewegt also für mich wirklich ein völlig
unnötiges Produkt und eine richtige
scheiß Idee äh mit der Angst der Leute
zu spielen und damit Kohle zu verdienen
finde ich scheiße euch freigestellt ob
ihr es kaufen wollt ich würde es auf gar
keinen Fall noch mal kaufen und beim
nächsten Pitch bitte nicht wieder
ausziehen für das nächste Produkt namens
popcornloop geht es wieder zurück in Max
Küche dieses Produkt verspricht das
perfekte Popcorn zu Hause machen zu
können besser als jedes Mikrowellen
Popcorn und genauso gut wie das aus dem
Kino Murat wollte 80.000 € für 35%
bekommen hat der 80.000 € für 35% von
Judith Williams und Buran Öger außerdem
1 € pro verkauftem Produkt zurück an die
beiden Investoren bis das Investment
zurück Smart ist ich bin sehr gespannt
ob dieses Produkt hält was es verspricht
die Entwicklung dieses Produktes hat
anscheinend schon in der neunten Klasse
gestartet weil der Erfinder ein
wirklicher Popcorn chronosseur ist es
ist zumindest schon mal ein komplettes
data set dabei folgendermaßen dieses
Baumwolltuch wird über den Topf gespannt
dazu hat man hier unten dann diesen Stab
und kann das Popcorn umrühren das
bedeutet es kommt kein Popcorn heraus
und ganz entscheidend dieses
Baumwolltuch nimmt die Feuchtigkeit auf
bzw lässt sie aus dem Topf was angeblich
dann zum perfekten Ergebnis führen
sollen dazu noch die richtigen Zutaten
und wir schauen uns jetzt an ob es
funktioniert und lassen vor allem
maximal probieren was er davon hält der
popcornloop den wir natürlich gleich mit
handelsüblichen fertigen Popcorn
vergleichen wollen dafür müssen wir zwei
Esslöffel Speiseöl in einen
unbeschichteten Kopf tun was mache ich
hiermit
wir bedecken den Boden
Popcorn Zucker davon 2 Esslöffel
so jetzt bedecken wir den mit dem
popcornloop jawohl popcornloop ist
montiert nach einer halben Minute mit
dem Rühren beginnen mit dem aufpoppen
der Maiskörner die Hitze des Herdes
reduzieren ich rühre also ich finde es
jetzt schon eine ziemlich smarte Idee
weil entweder du lässt halt den Deckel
beim Popcorn drauf und kannst nicht
rühren oder es kommt dazu dass das
Popcorn überall in der Küche verteilt
wird weil du den Deckel abnimmst man
hätte es deutlich weniger trashy wirken
lassen können wenn man das hier ein
bisschen ändert hätte aber es sieht fast
aus wie eine Weihnachts Edition weil
auch hier drauf ein Lebkuchen zu sehen
ist
Pop endlich
okay wir gehen mit der Hitze runter
jetzt wird nur noch gerührt und wir
lassen das Popcorn poppen
das geht schon wenig über so richtig
frisches Popcorn wir hatten tatsächlich
Probleme mikrowellenvorkommen zu finden
es ist scheinbar ausverkauft
da ist noch relativ wenig gepoppt
[Musik]
kann meist schlecht werden so dass er
weniger Pop wenn ich aber den Koch an
meiner Seite also wir haben es wirklich
nach Anleitung durchgeführt
also es sieht wirklich sehr enttäuschend
aus von der Logik her macht es keinen
Sinn dass das so ist
kann man merkt das in die Richtung geht
aber das ist natürlich ein
erschütterndes Ergebnis kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das gewünschte Ergebnis
war wir haben uns an die Anleitung
gehalten aber einfach und gut ist das
Ergebnis nicht dazu zum Vergleich
convenience von fertig Popcorn
schmeckt wunderbar ist natürlich nicht
frisch nicht mehr warm aber schmeckt
Option 2 auf
weniger süß schmeckt auch option 3
Mikrowellen Popcorn hat jedes Mal das
gewünschte Ergebnis und alles ist gut
also für Leute die richtig gerne Popcorn
Essen ist das hier eine Option da kann
man sich dann mehr mit beschäftigen und
gucken wo der Fehler lag und das alles
wunderbar machen die Idee das Konzept
und die Umsetzung an sich auch mega gut
aber das gewünschte Ergebnis war jetzt
auf eins für uns nicht so richtig
kombinieren zu erzählen
eher so das nächste Produkt begeistert
mich komplett wenn es denn wirklich
funktioniert
sich das Ganze angefragt hatten sie
100.000 € für 15% bekommen haben sie
150.000 € für 20%, wodurch sie im
Prinzip mehr Geld für ihre Prozente
bekommen haben und den Deal ist Ralf
Dümmel eingegangen wäre auch sonst im
Prinzip verspricht dieses Produkt eine
flüssige Display Beschichtung zu sein
und das ganze ohne unnötig schwer diese
dumme Folie aufzutragen tausende von
Blasen App runter zu haben und das hier
soll wirklich all diese Probleme lösen
und den Display bis zu 600 mal härter
machen das Ganze soll durch Nanotechnik
funktionieren die sonst in der Raumfahrt
benutzt wird oder auch bei Oldtimer
Versiegelung also quasi etwas das
wirklich einfach bewiesenermaßen Lack
oder Oberflächen schützt wahrscheinlich
dann extrem kleinen portioniert und
extrem teuer verkauft aber sei es ihm
gegönnt wenn sie es auf Handydisplays um
modellieren konnten hört sich eigentlich
zu gut an um wahr zu sein wir werden es
gemeinsam testen wenn dieses Produkt
hält was verspricht bin ich wirklich
mega begeistert wir schauen uns
gemeinsam an mit und ohne protext Pack
wir schauen rein das Display mit dem in
der Packung befindlichen Reinigungstuch
1 säubern anschließend trocknen lassen
die Flüssigkeit aus der Kartusche auf
das Display geben und gleichmäßig mit
dem Trockentuch verteilen und einreiben
wie und ob das funktionieren soll kann
ich gerade noch überhaupt nicht
einschätzen
dickflüssig das zieht aber ein 10
Minuten ab jetzt
10 Minuten rum es ist auf jeden Fall so
eine dickflüssige Masse die wir jetzt
mal quasi polieren können es fühlt sich
nicht anders an als vorher das hat man
ja häufig wenn man irgendwie eine
Displayfolie aufträgt dass sich ein
bisschen anders anfühlt als vorher das
ist ziemlich smooth jetzt kommt aber der
absolute Härtetest vielleicht ist die
Situation für dich und dein Handy
Display Schlüssel und Handy in derselben
Tasche
oh das war schon richtig Druck
noch mehr Druck nichts passiert ja gar
nichts
damit
[Musik]
passiert nicht nichts verrückt also ich
glaube gegen Kratzer gegen Sachen die so
im Alltag mit dem Handy gemeinsam in der
Hosentasche sind kann das tatsächlich
helfen ich bin kein Experte aber ich
würde sagen das trotzdem ein
aufgesetztes neues Glas gegen Fall gegen
Fall auf Kanten und so nach wie vor
besser funktioniert das ist eine
Versiegelung die funktioniert das wird
ja auch bei Autos benutzt also wer keine
Displayfolie oder kein Display Glas
benutzen will kommt hier auf seine
Kosten und es ist besser als gar nichts
auf dem Handy zu haben es ersetzt ein
aufgesetztes Glas aber nicht
so was soll ich sagen das Video ist zu
Ende ich befinde mich in Frankreich
nehme fünf Tage Auszeit bin bald schon
wieder für Euch da genauso wie das
nächste Video das schon ein paar Tagen
da kommt also vergesst nicht den Kanal
zu abonnieren das Video zu liken wenn es
euch gefallen hat ich freue mich sehr
jetzt in den nächsten Tagen direkt mit
dem büroumbau zu starten Kuss Kuss
[Musik]